when you like see some of these
younger artists um
who you might [ __ ] with
we i feel like recently we've just seen
so much [ __ ] going on in terms of
just
people keeping one foot in one foot out
on the rap [ __ ] and you know we see
people losing their freedom
we see people losing their life we see a
lot so much going on like like what
would be some advice you would give to
some of those younger artists who maybe
haven't
i i tell my artist all the time not to
even make this records not to even fall
into the negativity and understand this
come with the music game everybody's not
going to like you it's going to be a lot
of
people from your past to remember i
remember he wasn't doing this i remember
he had his like hater type [ __ ] you get
i'm saying so it comes with it you got
to have tough skin for it and if you
ain't ready for hate you ain't ready for
success
but then also you got to understand too
when you
when you coming from the hood or the
trenches and you um
you give these kids money that never had
money before
and they also had a street mentality
like it's like they feel like they can't
be touched
and really care about the certain things
that they should be worried about until
later on
yeah i'm saying so that's like well i
never choose to um like pop ecstasy or
pills and [ __ ] like that because a lot
of people from my neighborhood used to
get high and then they'd wake up
not knowing what they did later on in in
in the interrogation room wow you know
what i'm saying they'd be like what the
[ __ ] happened last night so like and i
knew a lot of people from my
neighborhood like lost their mind like
early like like young dudes like
20 years old like smoking crack now
because he didn't hit him pop the bad
ecstasy pill and [ __ ] him off and this
was like a fly [ __ ] i used to hoop and
and
get good grades in school you know i'm
saying something like man i never want
to play with myself like that you know
what i'm saying because i've seen how
you know just like how they doing it
right now are they pressing up the pills
with their phone type [ __ ] like that
people dying like this was back then
mm-hmm like yeah i'm saying this is the
hyphy movement days when
[ __ ] popping six xc pills losing their
mind like i'm saying like hell nah like
you never got down with that [ __ ] nah
never the only thing i ever did was
smoke weed ship syrup that was it
did you still sip nah i been stopping a
long time ago was that hard to stop
because i know some people say it's
pretty tough to get off no it wasn't
hard um
my whole thing i was i was abused and i
was getting too high it wasn't hard from
when i kicked it it was like
i damn near like
not paying attention when i would be
doing that damn they're probably simple
breaking the day
yeah i'm saying because i used to when i
used to buy a pint i used to have like
the 20 ounce cream sodas and i poured
like a four in there in each one of them
and i didn't drunk like four of them and
i'm
[ __ ] off again i'm saying not even
knowing i shoot a video i actually i
shot a video somebody came in town paid
me for a verse in the video i shot the
video
i drunk one right here doing this scene
one at this scene one at this scene one
in this scene that's a whole brick yo
that's crazy because i'm not even paying
attention to what i'm doing it's so it's
so good but you know they say something
that something that's that good ain't
that too good for you
so uh one day i woke up you know um
i walked up [ __ ] up one day and i was
like man if i make him man i'm done
and i just been done ever since damn
yeah that's good man yeah yeah i feel
like you know the lean thing is like
obviously like you said it's something
that people really enjoy but it's also
like
it it's like your body can become
dependent on it and
it's just like if you're drinking a good
ass soda and
you just keep drinking that [ __ ] over
and over and you're going to keep
drinking it but you're not knowing that
the sugar or whatever the caffeine or
whatever is [ __ ] you up inside you
don't even realize it until it gets too
late yeah that's real [ __ ]